I thought I was really competitive at
first and then I played you in
basketball f gm7 and realized I'm not
competitive at all okay and then I had
to step up my game you think you get
more competitive with people that around
you or yes actually you know what I'm so
proud of you for asking this question
actually I really do I'm surprised I'm
so excited by this I have a good piece
of advice actually start trimming your
friend group and start adding to your
friend group predicated on what you want
to be the answer is absolutely my man
like you absolutely I am stunned how
much more I am like my wife and how much
more she is like me even though we
started a very polar places it's just
true who you hang out with like there is
such a smart hack to like and it's
really the like that cliche thing like
you are like the byproduct and people
like all that's real super real so maybe
this is a good year for you to like kind
of audit that first day back look around
maybe know a friend of a friend and if
you like what you see go explore it and
try to be around it because yeah man I
think that you got more competitive by
being around me and I can tell you right
now I know everybody on my team they're
different I'll tell you one thing that I
can tell you firm about the rock and
Nate for sure I'll give you those two
examples they're a fuckload more
confident they work than they were when
they came into my life because my
confidence rubbed off on them straight
up